[Music]
we want baber and mid suffolk to
continue to be places that people are
proud to call home
and we have created our joint local plan
as a blueprint to help provide bright
and healthy futures for our districts
we have a legal responsibility to
deliver this plan
setting out where new homes will be
built in our districts and how we will
meet government housing requirements
up to 2037. affordable housing is a key
component of the plan
so that everyone can afford to live and
work in the places where they grew up
but it's not just homes that are being
built it is communities
the plan also details important
infrastructure
such as schools highways improvements
gp surgeries and other community
facilities
to ensure that we meet the needs of our
growing and changing population
sustainable transport options as well as
biodiversity
and environmental measures have been
promoted in the plan
as part of our council's ongoing
commitment to addressing climate change
our plan will also help us regenerate
key market towns
such as hadley sudbury stone market
needham market and i at a time
when economic growth and employment
opportunities
are needed more than ever i've been a
councillor for almost 30 years
and believe that the hard work and
commitment of officers together with the
council of working group
has produced a plan of the highest
quality backed up with more evidence
than i have ever seen support a plan
baba is a fantastic place to live work
and visit
and our plan aims to protect our
wonderful landscape
and areas of outstanding natural beauty
with its rich heritage
there's much to be proud of in our
district
the plan is set to preserve and enhance
what makes mid-suffolk special whilst
managing growth in our communities
for years to come how
and where development takes place is
incredibly important to us all
thank you to everyone who participated
in our previous public consultations
your views have helped shape our
district's future and ensured that our
plan includes the right options
and priorities our councils have now
submitted our plan
along with the final representations
received to an independent planning
inspector
appointed by government for examination
before
our joint local plan can be adopted
please visit our website for further
information
and updates as the plan progresses
you